Welcome back.
As you guys know, we're always striving to get better
here at "The Tonight Show."
♪ Harder, better, faster, stronger ♪
[ Laughter ] So, before every show,
we put out a suggestion box for the audience
just to get some feedback about what you guys think of the show,
things you would like to us do, that kind of stuff.
So tonight let's look inside the Audience Suggestion Box.
Here we go.
-♪ Look into the box, the suggestion box ♪
-This first one here is from Sheena Brooks.
"Hey, Jimmy, I just went to see 'Beetlejuice: The Musical'
on Broadway, and it was amazing.
I wish there were musical versions
of other Halloween movies. Can you help?"
Well, it's not really a Halloween movie, but they're
actually working on a musical reboot of "The Shining."
-Really? -Yeah, it looks pretty good.
Here's a sneak peek.
♪♪
-♪ Little pigs, little pigs ♪
♪ Let me come in ♪
-♪ Ahh-ahh ♪
♪ Not by the hair on your chinny chin, chin! ♪
-♪ Ahh, ahh ♪ -♪ Ahh, ahh ♪
-♪ Don't ♪
♪ Jack, please, ahh ♪
-♪ I'll huff ♪ -♪ Ahh ♪
-♪ I'll puff ♪ -♪ Ahh ♪
♪ And I'll blow your house in ♪
-♪ Ahh ♪
-♪ Here's Johnny! ♪
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow! -Wow. Scary, huh?
-I'm gonna go see that. -Scary.
Let's try another one. This is from Emmy Dyer.
"Hey, Jimmy, do you think you can toss an apple-cider donut
and have it land on Higgins' head?"
That's a good question. There's only one way to find out.
You ready, Higgins?
-Yep.
-It goes like this way or...? -Like that way. Yeah.
-Toss it like that? -There you go.
-Like that way? -You got it.
-Or that way? -That way.
I would say like a frisbee.
[ Pop! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ] Not bad.
Don't forget the hole, Joel!
[ Pop! ]
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is from Randy McStine.
"Hey, Jimmy, the FIFA World Cup is coming up, and I can't wait.
My favorite thing about the game is when the guy yells,
'G-o-o-o-ol' after someone scores.
I wonder what it would sound like if he yelled 'Lizzo.'"
Well, we can make that happen right now.
Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome the legend himself,
Andrés Cantor, a.k.a. "Mr. Gol,"
saying the word "Lizzo."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Lizz-o-o-o-o-o-o-o-o!
-That's what I'm talking about! Andrés Cantor!
Andrés, thank you, buddy.
Legend. Legend.
Alright. We'll do one last one here.
-Alright. Great.
-Alright. Here we go. We'll do one last one here.
It's from Sarah Munson.
"Hey, Jimmy, I'm a big fan of Ford trucks,
and I especially love
their all-new F-Series Super Duty pickup truck."
It's awesome. Work hard, play hard.
The problem is, I love trivia games that involve a giant pie
made of whipped cream being launched
at someone from a catapult.
Is there any way you can combine those things?"
Well, Sarah, you're in luck because...
[ Laughter ] -Wow.
-There's a Ford Super Duty down in the 30 Rock Plaza
with a catapult attached to it
that can launch a giant whipped cream pie through the air.
Let's do this!
Wanna do this? Come on, Higg. Come on, Tariq.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hey, guys, we're down in the 30 Rock Plaza.
Tariq and I are about to play the Ford Mega Pie Challenge.
Higgins, tell us how it works. -Well, the game is simple.
In front of you is a Ford Super Duty
equipped with a whipped-cream catapult.
You'll answer trivia questions
designed to test your knowledge about the Super Duty.
If you guess right, you move on.
If you guess wrong, you must press the cream launcher,
which will randomly trigger the giant pie to be thrown at you.
Alright. Here's your first question.
-I'm a pumpkin hauler myself.
Pumpkins average around 4 pounds per pumpkin.
-Oh, my God. -I'm gonna say my answer is B.
-B. That is correct!
10,000 pumpkins.
Tariq, it's your turn in the cream zone.
And here's your question.
-I'm gonna say "A." I'm gonna say "A."
-"A."
[ Buzzer ] Ooh, sorry.
"C, 360 degrees.
-Oh, great.
You must now press the cream launcher.
-Yeah! Come on! -Which may or may not
trigger the pie to be catapulted unto you.
Good luck. -Good luck, bud.
[ Suspenseful music ]
♪♪
[ Ding ]
-Ohh. -Whew!
-Unbelievable. -Jimmy -- You survived, Tariq.
Jimmy, you're up. Your question is...
-So does the truck have the torque of a truck?
-Does it? That's up to you.
-Trying to trick me, but sure. -You're gonna go "A"?
-Yeah.
[ Buzzer ] -Ooh. Wrong!
It is "B," a semi truck.
Jimmy, press the cream launcher.
Good luck!
[ Suspenseful music ]
♪♪
[ Ding ]
Ohh! You survived.
Tariq, you're up. -Unh!
-I'm gonna go "D," all of the above.
-This is insane. -That is correct! "D." Yes!
Alright, Jimmy, your question. -I know.
[ Laughter ]
-Is it, "A," eggs and toast...
"B," cereal...
"C," steel-cut oatmeal...
or, "D," a raspberry pain au chocolat
with a quiche Lorraine and a warm hazelnut ganache
with a hint of cinnamon? -Hint of cinnamon.
-I am definitely going -- I've been to breakfast with you.
It is "D."
[ Buzzer ] -Oh, no!
Of course, it's "C," steel-cut oatmeal.
Come on, man! Time to press it, baby.
Press the launcher. -Moment of truth.
[ Suspenseful music ]
♪♪
[ Engine revs ]
[ Mozart's "Requiem in D Minor" plays ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
-That's all the time we have for Suggestion Box.
Thank you so much to Ford. Really, thank you, Ford.
We'll be right back with more "Tonight Show," everybody.
Oh, my gosh.
-♪ ...my favorite cartoon ♪
♪ After that, there's a honeymoon ♪